[Applaudissements] [Musique] sur scène aujourd'hui et je veux dire que nous avons littéralement Daenerys, nous avons Cersei, nous avons Jon Snow, nous avons Killian, mais quelques-uns sont tous au bord de quelque chose de désastreux, l'ambiance est sombre, c'est vous savez
les dirigeants du monde s'unissent et ne sont pas d'accord sur la façon dont le monde devrait être dirigé, ils peuvent aller très rapidement vers le sud et c'est une partie brillante de cette séquence parce que vous savez à quelle vitesse les choses peuvent tourner dans cette émission, c'est un baril de poudre potentiel, donc peu importe ce qui se passe, peu importe qui est
rencontrer qui le potentiel pour que les choses explosent complètement est toujours là la fosse aux dragons est probablement l'une des séquences de C les plus essentielles de tout Game of Thrones Tyrion et son groupe, ils savent qu'ils entrent dans un endroit dangereux et ils savent qu'ils prennent un
risquez de venir ici, vous avez plus de 60 heures à ce stade de personnages principaux dans lesquels vous êtes vraiment investi et c'est agréable de réunir des gens qui n'ont jamais été ensemble auparavant et de voir
comment ils réagiraient les uns aux autres, ce sont les gens qui prennent conscience de leur petitesse, je pense que dans leur nature, peu importe à quel point ils se battent, il y a une plus grande menace pour la vie que juste qui est sur le trône, vous pouvez dire à quiconque vous savez que cette maladie est
venir mais jusqu'à ce que vous puissiez leur montrer la preuve qu'ils ne surmonteront pas leurs propres petits problèmes pour combattre le gros problème que ces choses construisent au fil du temps en 50 à 70 heures pour arriver à ce point, il faut 70 heures pour que l'histoire permette cette scène
pour arriver, il y a un élan qui est en place maintenant qui ne s'arrête pas, donc c'est vraiment excitant, c'est incroyable parce que je suis le petit nouveau sur le bloc et j'ai vu ces gars pendant six saisons maintenant, puis tout d'un coup faire partie de leur scène
Je pense que cela va être l'une des scènes de cette saison, le dragonpit incarne le défi central de la saison sept où nous avons une douzaine de quatre personnages principaux tous au même endroit dont beaucoup ne se sont pas vus depuis un v
très dramatique incident des années auparavant entre eux, donc cette scène était incroyablement difficile à écrire et incroyablement difficile à filmer vous voulez pouvoir servir tous ces personnages et c'était extrêmement amusant de tracer des conflits entre des personnes des amitiés entre des personnes lesquelles vous vouliez
mettez en surbrillance celles que vous allez devoir laisser tomber, vous savez que des dizaines de mini-scènes ressemblent à des dizaines de petites scènes, nous avons donc dû trouver de grands moments, des interactions avec les personnages et une histoire pour tous ces personnages, ce qui est tellement amusant
écrire pour tous ces gars ensemble, cela nous a en quelque sorte obligés à vraiment explorer quelles étaient les différentes variations tonales de ces réunions, vous savez, c'est essayer de garder un œil sur ce pour quoi ils sont tous là, je veux dire qu'ils sont tous là pour une raison
qui est de discuter de la possibilité d'une alliance et si c'est même possible avec ces gens qui ont tant de raisons de se détester et donc quelques raisons de se faire confiance
se saluent le lancement du pod le siège LEM Je veux dire que ce gars était la personne la plus importante au monde pour lui, il était la seule personne qui lui avait donné une chance Je suis content que tu sois en vie, il y a quelque chose de très doux dans
et parmi tous les gros trucs, les petits trucs se produisent toujours aussi et cela ajoute encore à la texture du spectacle Je pense que ce truc n'a jamais oublié ce qu'il y a dedans [ __ ] il y a un moment vraiment merveilleux où Brienne espionne le chien et elle se rend compte que
elle doit en quelque sorte s'excuser peut-être d'avoir failli le tuer peut-être, mais elle lui apporte également la nouvelle qu'elle sait qu'il veut entendre qu'Arya est vivante et qu'elle est à la maison oh c'était un soulagement oui bien sûr et une préoccupation est-elle bien
m.
envoyer un texto à la terre, vous êtes ici, toute personne qui a besoin de protection est celle qui vous gêne, puis il s'avère que nous n'avons pas besoin de nous inquiéter pour Arya parce que je lui ai tout appris ce que j'aime dans la relation entre Tyrion et le bronze, c'est qu'ils savent
réellement qui ils sont Tyrion le pousse un peu à quel point bran fait des choses par intérêt personnel ne vous inquiétez pas pour moi je vais bien en prenant soin de moi êtes-vous en train de m'aider à organiser cette réunion ne regardait pas exactement
après toi c'était c'est ta reine en chef dit qu'il s'est offert un sac d'or force pas le mien frappe un peu sur son cœur d'étain sait un peu qu'il y a quelque chose là-dedans c'est bon de te revoir ouais toi aussi tu as Cersei Cink Tyrion pour la première fois en
longtemps son ennemi mortel donc la première fois qu'ils se regardent quand elle entre c'est un moment c'est vraiment gênant c'est comme moi je sais que les réunions de famille pour tout le monde sont très gênantes mais bon disons simplement que les Lannister sont compliqués
Bunch, elle l'a tenu responsable de la mort de sa mère et de la mort de Joffrey et de son père, vous savez qu'elle ne peut pas vraiment assumer ses responsabilités ou faire face à son propre chagrin, elle doit simplement blâmer tout le monde et cela fait partie de sa douleur aussi Lina donne
moi un regard que je ne veux plus jamais revoir c'est ouais si je pouvais presque m'aplatir je voulais me cacher mon frère comme c'est bon j'ai eu une confrontation avec lui ce qui était très amusant j'étais super en l'ignorant une situation très grave derrière juste
va directement à lui va essentiellement toi et moi copain nous n'avons pas fini tu comprends il y a une chose non verbale de quatre ou cinq secondes entre Cersei Jaime et Brienne ce n'est même pas une ligne de dialogue c'est juste une petite mini scène de construit à partir de
on dirait que c'est un peu l'une des pires choses qui vous arrivent à l'école, je pense que c'est l'idée de Brian d'un enfer abject absolu, combattre le chien était un enfer abject, mais un moment où il faut faire face à Jaime et Cersei est le plus exc
chose émouvante qui pourrait éventuellement arriver à Brienne, elle arrive avec la montagne et Jamie, puis comme vous dites le Kingsguard et elle est vous savez assez féroce, puis elle se rend compte que Danny n'est pas là et cela la fait chier évidemment et puis bien sûr Danny
arrive sur dragon tu sais que je prends la mode en retard - de nouveaux sommets [Musique] elle est très théâtrale avec son entrée bien que oui c'est assez drôle que yo wow elle doive vraiment montrer son pouvoir mais assez juste et elle essaie désespérément de ne pas
être impressionné par cette arrivée et tout le monde évidemment car vous étiez juste debout dans tout cela et ensuite vous savez en promenade cette jeune beauté d'une reine et elle est immédiatement au-delà de la frustration à plusieurs niveaux, nous sommes ici depuis un certain temps mes excuses et
alors tout ce qu'elle obtient de Danny, ce sont des excuses, vous savez, et cela la conduit ensuite dans la scène, elle ne peut pas le supporter, nous avons quelque chose à vous montrer, mais pour moi, étant un nerd d'horreur, j'étais un peu gloussant
ugh mais mes très jeunes zombies, elle n'a jamais rien vu de tel auparavant et c'est une créature qui la défie c'est une créature qu'elle ne sait pas comment désactiver elle ne sait pas comment tuer c'est quelque chose d'autre que Daenerys a vu
et elle en est consciente, c'est effrayant mais elle regarde juste Cersei comme si elle avait juste besoin de savoir que cela l'a affectée, vous savez, elle a toujours eu cette notion de créatures comme celle-ci qu'elles n'existent pas et c'est un non-sens et donc je pense que quand
il est là, elle est de retour en tant qu'enfant, mais vous savez que réaliser tout ce que sa grand-mère, ses nounous lui ont dit était réel, elle regarde un visage qu'elle n'aurait jamais cru exister pour Jamie, c'est comme une preuve définitive qu'ils ont qu'il n'y a pas de choix clairement ce
chose dans laquelle nous devons faire face à cela et ensuite il les croit tous, il croit son frère mais il croit aussi en Daenerys et John Snow et quand ils disent qu'ils ont vu cent mille de ces êtres c'est là que
re sa tête est tu sais que le monde pourrait se terminer en cinq minutes mais il est absolument un point sur lequel il s'était concentré je n'ai jamais vu ça avant c'est incroyable je pourrais vraiment faire ça tu sais il y a ce rythme dans la scène que j'aime vraiment
parce que j'ai une file d'attente où il est comme s'il venait de voir le Walker blanc qu'elle vient de mourir et vous réalisez que c'est la première chose qu'il ait jamais vue qui le terrifie et c'est comme une nouvelle émotion pour lui vous savez oh j'étais j'étais c'était un
sentiment intéressant je retourne sur mon île tu devrais retourner sur la tienne quand les hivers seront terminés nous serons les seuls à rester en vie et ensuite tout repose sur la mort de ses dragons tout repose sur Jon Snow juste allongé la couronne accepte ta trêve dans
revenir le roi dans le nord prolongera cette trêve il restera dans le nord où il appartient il ne prendra pas les armes contre les Lannister il ne choisira pas son camp ils ont un plan d'action et puis tout s'effondre avec l'honneur de Jon
un
gagner si je viens mec
comme si c'était tout ce que tu as à faire juste
cette fois, dis juste un mensonge et tu ne peux pas
il ne peut tout simplement pas aimer que c'était le mauvais coup
qui était un mauvais choix mais merci beaucoup
je suis fidèle à  ma parole ou j'essaie d'être
c'est pourquoi je ne peux pas vous donner ce que vous demandez, je
ne peux pas servir deux reines
Tyrion connaissant si bien ses sœurs sait si bien
que ça ne va pas bien se passer et
bien sûr ça ne marche pas et quand John fait
ça le tout  la chose s'effondre donc c'est un
peu comme si je comprenais mais ensuite il n'y a plus
rien à discuter c'est tellement
amusant
avec nous tous tous ensemble ayant été
isolés pendant si longtemps et puis tout à coup
boum je travaille avec tout le monde était
une sorte d'événement  pour moi c'était j'ai
adoré c'est charmant c'est nous tous
ensemble c'est tout genre de vous
savez c'était vraiment excitant parce que nous sommes
tous juste une grande famille heureuse et cela
s'est prolongé et après le travail malheureusement
parce que nous nous sommes beaucoup trop amusés toi  se
connaissent généralement comme vous l'avez dit et puis vous
avez un AK de l'autre  r acteurs avec qui sortir
du coup nous étions comme 15 10 15 dans le
même hôtel c'était juste une recette pour un
désastre mais c'était amusant bien qu'ayant
été tellement investi dans la série pendant si longtemps
pendant tant d'années c'est tellement excitant
et j'étais  personnellement très excité de
rencontrer enfin Daenerys et j'espère pour les
fans qu'ils verront une
réalisation satisfaisante de ce que je pense qu'ils
attendront peut-être, c'est que ces mondes
entrent en collision ces dix jours ont été 10 des
jours les plus agréables que j'ai jamais  passé à
faire ce spectacle parce que ce sont tous ces
gens qui passent un si bon moment
juste en compagnie les uns des autres Je
n'oublierai jamais ces jours et sur ce
plateau, ils étaient exceptionnels
Game of Thrones Assessor mis sur l'
exclusivité Yosemite ne nous a jamais plu
COC Lucas ou cinéma Siri
Oh seus c'était amusant tu vois